hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation mapping the inner
world of the cell presented by dr. Boll
Quang professor Department of
pharmaceutical chemistry biochemistry
and biophysics university of california
san francisco i am xavier gutierrez of
lab rats and i will be your moderator
for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
Reed's lab roots is the leading social
networking website and producer of
educational or short events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to tune your credits
now please join me in welcoming dr. King
I will turn the presentation over to him
here I would like to share our
experience of getting to the inner works
of the cell and try to see what's
happening inside a cell as all of our
cell biologists want to do is that we
really want to see all the details in
the cells to see what's happening what's
the mechanism behind it and how we can
use it to understand these fundamental
processes and how we can use it to to to
better our healthcare and we know the
cell is very small it's just the thing
just the fraction of millimeters to
several
there and takes a microscope to really
get in there and see all this detailed
structures as all of us when going to a
not so familiar city and we would need a
map we wouldn't not know where
everything is when were the most
important attraction is and that's when
something happens we know what it is we
know where to where to find it so and
nowadays with the advancements of the
imaging techniques we can use it take a
picture of the city here's some of you
may recognize that this is a city of San
Francisco which in picture of the city
from Santa is from think well above the
sky and then if we have anything that's
a good marker of the place of interest
we know where they are we can show a map
of the city so this is my own hand-drawn
map of the San Francisco city with none
of tourist attractions a marked of
course one of the most important
abstraction that I suggest MiG to visit
is VCS F and UCSF uses are pretty much
everywhere in a day actually this is the
Sinister express want to start doing a
Mac of the cell that's we have a cell
there and well we first need to enable
the structure of interest
this is typically down by either for
some protein of worse than anybody so
that's whatever structure may interest
now has the color now has some signals
of messages that's coming out and then
we put our structure put our cell under
a microscope and microscopes and capture
the signal and produce an image then
we'll send an image to our computer the
computer will analyze an image and key
tell us the answer that completes the
full path from cell to cell and this is
basically involving a lot of
technologies the minor apps team working
hard to develop and that's the that's
the pipeline that we are working on now
we've been working on string structures
in neighboring imaging and analysis and
today's job are we mostly Beefalo see
our the neighboring aspects and we've
been looking at a lot of different sera
structures when using a different not
different naming methods mean for
example we'll be using anybody in
universes in conjugation with super
microscopy as a way to see the ultra
structures of the scenery transition
zone that's a collaboration with Germany
writer and UCSF and we have also been
developing methods that can label the
DNA then using the CRISPR caste 9 system
so that I can follow the movements or
the dynamics of genes in the nucleus in
a living cell and more importantly you
can't have all the other structures in a
Cell and especially for live imaging one
of the most common use of practice will
be the first protein in this case if you
want to follow a protein of interest in
a new minister what we typically do is
to make a possible to do protein fusion
construct this protein of interest the
fuse to chew up frozen protein and then
we'll express this fusion construct in a
cell then we get incorporated into the
target structure and then we can follow
its movement for its dynamics for his
next cycle and this is so ubiquitous in
practiced and it's extremely powerful
technique as to learn what's going on in
living cells it's not to say that
doesn't have limitations in for example
here's a very nice illustration we know
the typical practice is that we have the
target protein refuse it to the first
protein we overexpressed in a cell and
daenerys or explain of expression is
changing the concentration or change in
expression level of this target protein
for many of the targets the serving this
change is very well tolerated so we
don't see much thing going wrong but
example this is my own experience there
are certain proteins if you just over
expressed this change then when we try
to look at the anaplastic particularly
our protein and we're trying to feed
out the ER distribution of two proteins
one working for a which is a trivial
protein and then when we overexpress it
the ER is full of tubes and the other
thing is the pin 63 is that your sheet
forming protein and will we overexpress
that one the entire yama forges changes
the oceans sheet or lowercase so it's
just the other expression is actually
changing the structure of interest
itself and that makes it difficult to
understand exactly what's going on with
the endogenous yard with the indulgent
of origin of ER with endogenous
expression of proteins this is one task
were trying to mean trying to go after
this is the one we're method were trying
to establish an efficient effective way
of naming imaging and analyze endogenous
proteins well nowadays ways the
advancements of protein adding
techniques it is been getting more and
more routine to label endogenous
proteins using say using for using a
green fluorescent protein GFP and that
is well you have a GTG in your ad how
much armed with the CRISPR cast iron
system you can make a cuts I was from
break at the target site then homologous
recombination will incorporate the GFP
gene into the genome and then in the
audience we this target protein is
tagged with a green fluorescent protein
so that you can track the dynamics of
this in guardians protein when this has
been and very successful approach and
now seeing many many papers no published
using the largest ship in neighboring
using generic well it's effective
doesn't mean that it isn't having helped
Ramos the GE gene is not small it's over
Sarah how the base pair and to make
doing hormones recombination efficient
typically people ask that one KB how
much arm on a two
so the whole donor DNA is one 2kb
it takes from multiple steps of Kony to
make that order to the knick that door
and DNA and lucky because the donor size
the insert size is big the home of
commission is not necessarily always
efficient so there are many cases of
successful GMP integration and that ends
up with beautiful papers there are also
many cases some of them coming from our
own experience that it is fairly it's
difficult to get a in gently integral
sell my for certain genomic Nosa so
we're trying to change that we know that
thing about this problem roots in the
fact that chip is big well can we have
some label that's smaller it needs to be
a label as small and it needs to be
enabled that become frozen by itself so
that's we do have her than shoe to a
second step memory to serve this problem
the approach that we're coming up
actually the idea of Edgecam hama a
former scientist of that aside as Kenya
former post up on that and together was
doing phone a extreme talents about
doing graduate students you know that is
that we don't have to enable the turret
protein with the entire frozen protein
instead we can take the advantage of the
speed for some protein system in this
case we only need to put a small
fragment of the frozen fully on a
protein may interest well we have the
other the other big fragment just
protein a cerveza
and this to fragment once see each other
isn't complement and then to
reconstitute a fully functional person
project in this way then the insert can
be much smaller for this purpose in
fortunately Geoffrey model rabbit and
Ozma husband national poetry has already
engineered a speech ERP system and the
speak point is between the 10th and
in essence yes threat the to fragment by
itself especially the tenth fragment
which contained the residue that
uniformed therefore some protein and
then they cannot mature by itself
because a key kinetically residue is on
a smaller fragment and then only when
the two friends coming together they
would the forefoot could matter a good
mature and the whole thing could press
and even more importantly in the world
that has specifically engineer this
suite for some protein construct so that
they would very efficiently come
together without the assistance of other
protein protein interactions we know
many of the suite modes including
constructs being engineers to detect
contemporary veterans so you fuse one
part without approaching heart so
protein B so if it interacts would be
the to speak fragments will come
together and this is different they just
come together by very fish by the by
itself and that's the system what I
wouldn't use for some initial tests we
tried it to overexpress the GM endemic
construct the GOP budget and construct
we can see it works on a variety of
proteins as a protein naming joke and we
can also fuse Jim in Devon to a yharnam
M protein and have JP mono turn tant
with the ER trusted trust occasion
signal peptide so then sends in the ER
we can able yeah no me no proteins or
even extracellular domain of
transmembrane proteins so that's a
general enough method to neighbor
overexpress Borden's whereabouts
endogenous proteins
well the chip in Devon in this case is
very small it's only 16 amino acids
including linker we can put everything
into a DNA of sixteen nucleotides and we
add 17 nucleotide home on your arm on
both ends the whole donor DNA is just
200 nucleotides can directly buy it from
dean service companies like a dt and
that makes not just
the integration is very efficient but
also the whole process cost-effective
because we have synthetic donor DNA and
that cost the feeling they seem tens of
dollars and we don't need to do any
combing for the whole process for the
knocking we've been clamoring with the
Jonathan West man that car is inspired
by the work done by John Tobias man I
don't know shearmur 10 years ago I'm
making the floor since is the memory so
this library has a collection of more
than 2,000 strains each string with a
protein in dart is attacked by green
filling by GOP so the important thing in
this case is that it comes a very
powerful discovery tool a URI people
think force microscopy has something
something you know what to do cut then
you can label it with a GFP you can look
at it you can identify where it's coming
from
we can analyze the behavior target
protein but once you have this
tambourine force microscopy become a
very powerful primary discouraged
because you don't have to take up a
hypothesis you can just go on Basti with
a image space to the screen and identify
the gene of interest and this yeast
memory has been very powerful in
analyzing the others sub sub
sterilization and you can say a nice
team certain important pathways involved
for example with East aging and very
harmful discourage hope and now with our
method that we can tag in orders
proteins we're wondering we can do the
same thing for mammalian cells so we've
been hiring with Jonathan Weissman AB
especially with Marilyn Mariner Nancy a
postdoc in Jonathas not with who's been
working on whispered engineering and the
protocol that's in Mario's developed was
based on the cast iron key methods
basically we have in ritual transcribed
gather all a mix with cast 9 and
nuclear protein compact mix with our
synthetic door early in May we're doing
that separation into the target cell
line that's already expressing the 110
fragment and then was the g11 is
integrated the we can use fax order to
sort out those integrated cells because
they are fluorescent he is encased with
the knock into the damaging we saw text
respect 36% of the exit 23 T is that
becomes fluorescent and we played them
we can verify their forces intensity
coming from the nuclear envelope so the
whole procedure takes one day and
experiment and a couple days for the
cell to grow up before me into the pic
of people into the story and cost about
$150 that's very cost-effective and
because our goal is to establish a
method that we can really scale this
method up to a large scale we I asked
him just a manual and daiji and Sega but
try to pick their favorite a leading
genes and try to make a mini library so
the three of them spent three weeks one
week to hit the target gene and design a
sequences while we were week to wait for
IDG to go to synthesize the DNA
understand us the nucleotide and another
week later we have a cell lines we have
a total of twelve yarn proteins because
of site has personal interest in Yama
for g2 of the metal Kandra proteins five
of the genes associated with the South's
curtain and centrosome the eight of them
associate with the nucleus there's a
clattering for an asset asses are
grabbing even for recycling endosomes
and then one for lysosomes and BK
because of other projects in that that's
working on the protein kinase a so out
of the forty eight targets the initially
picked
three of them we amira guards facts are
themselves as the sturdy we typically
have somewhere between eight to forty
percent of the in fact positive
ourselves and that is a very efficient
process we can plot the the wholesale
force intensity mayor but that's against
the expression that was made of IRA was
on profiling it's a pretty nice linear
correlation and if in for those ones
that did not result in any facts
positive signal
those are was the in ground color can
see those were those are wise that
typically of no expression that will
kind of falling below the facts
detection limit so if we said our
fastest session limit that's about
twenty seven matee can say the threshold
of whether we can get successful
knocking or not this with this threshold
we will say that's in happiness routine
so 30 percent of genome is expressed
above this level so theoretically
speaking that we take the same approach
we should be up to to the knocking and
cover about 30 percent of the time in
the genome being happy 3 T cells so that
would great it doesn't mean that with
those wires that's falling for below
this pressure and we don't getting
degree cells and if you look at crevice
that we actually have 31 images one of
the the images coming from 935 is a
nuclear pouring it's too weak to be
detected by fast but we if we place the
mixed population we can still see
nuclear have enough signal coming from
the fraction of the previous cell so
it's there you just the signal is not
strong enough for our frosting cell
sorter to detect it well it also means
if we can amplify the signal further we
will be have a much better coverage of
the whole genome if we were to create
knocking sir
then previously we've been doing is we
have tally protein wait a beauty with a
copy of GAAP after GOP melon to bring in
Egypt when the tests are reconstitutes
for GFP and our limitation of singer was
coming from the limitation of brightness
and GRP and that's terrible
very difficult in crew because people
have been working on JP for so many
years that's to try to perfect it how
the brain how to make it brighter well
initially which fries the brute force
way and we did it and if one copy of G
is not brunette
how about having multiple multiple
copies with G at peace but this isn't
inspired by the Sun tech methods coming
out over from Vale stab at ucsf basic
idea is GOP Nevin is sure enough we
should be able to arrange into teller
repeats and then multiple copies of GOP
Nevin will be able to bring multiple
copies of the G of U in the 10 and that
reconstituted motor-car copies of
fluorescent GFP to amplify the signal
we're trying this approach with 1x GOP
lemon 3 X 7 X either with a 15 amino
acid linker in between the repeats or
with five amazing linker we saw
proportional amplification of the signal
that's nice
and here is our collaboration with the
Wallace Marshall dad tried to do the
single particle tracking using either
for that GFP
or 7xj pin 11 in the t20 protein in the
flagella and in primary cilium and you
can see how much brighter when we have
seven copies of GOP 11 a nice thing is
that at least for this test of at 20
either with GOP or 7 that ship in heaven
we did not see a significant change in
the transfer speed of these particles
and so it means that the function of
this action is not perturbed by having
seven copies GOP tiry tiry on it so now
we are a
pretty easy way of amplify the signal
and improve our detection threshold
well the flipside is that now with the
gene insert is larger and we cannot just
directly sanitize the donor DNA the Nano
has worked out the protocol using in
vitro transcription and reverse
transcription to make that single strand
or DNA with multiple copies in Chipping
Evan and we tried it out also the 19
gene and here about the same equation
efficiency with 4x JB Nevin we got four
times as bright signal which is seeing
both the facts in facts histogram as
well as your forces for image we also
have to note that even with 14 7x chip
in heaven is still much smaller than jpg
in itself because GFP contained in every
bit of strength plus an alpha helix was
G in Evans just one of the better strand
so it is a pretty effective way of
amplify the signal and if we decrease
our detection threshold by a factor of
four we should have we should be able to
cover 60% of genome in 23 t-cells not be
nice
still it'd be nice if we can have a
small attack and for this purpose Nancy
has looked at a newly engineer for some
protein and neon green and the fullest I
mean green is about a factor of 2 to 3
as bright as for that GOP so that's
great and she has engineered a speaker
from that with more mutations to make
itself complimenting and so here we can
do we can do a meal green to in Devon
knocking to the 3 in jeans and they are
much brighter the other benefit is well
we have not realized this issue with
until we you really need that data very
carefully
that's for whatever reason and cells
expressing gfp when the time has higher
for some background compared to cells
non Express
anything and if you neck that D orange
curve that's GOP 110 expressed in cell
with a high explained with a strong
promoter we can reduce the expression
strength if you look at the blue curve
and the bad ones door and still there
we're not sure whether this is from some
very weak residue forces coming out JPL
Newton or it's anybody other forces
coming up gp1 Chen and it's a very weak
for us in frozen background basically on
the same order magnitude compared to the
compared to the autocross background so
it never affects other applications are
the powerful applications of the speed
GFP when since the j-pin nervous system
but in our case we're trying to detect a
know expressing protein this becomes an
issue becomes the bad ones higher in
comparison the amnion green is monetized
almost zero backgrounds totally
overlapped with the auto forces curve so
if you look at history on the right and
compare the GOP in heaven knocking
versus onion wind never knocking for a
no expressing protein you can see the
amnion green case is a much better
separated from non entry cells because
of lower back route so that is our
another advantage of this new green
system basically for this reason we're
pretty much all squished you and then
green in our own experiments nowadays
well now we can do very efficient
knocking for green color frozen unfrozen
protein and in green is slightly red
shifted compared to GAAP but since
interest you green colored it we nice to
have a second color so that we can do
double knocking and we can see cooling
pool interactions or relative position
of different proteins when it comes to
being multicolor imaging with GE one of
the classic tablets we want a classic
frozen
will be and cherry well we try to stay
I'm cherry but in end up with no fussing
Sigrid all this is not surprising
because the speak GFP is not sweet egfp
it's actually the water lab started with
the engineering a super coded version of
GP for very efficient fuel voting and
then further engineering after making
the switch to beginning fish in the
compliment
there's no wonder if we sprint the
ordinary a medium green it doesn't work
well what to do
we tries the most powerful research
engine Google and what's happing super
folder sharing a paper didn't come out
and it was also from the world of nap
and it was their work and but it was
published in a very obscure crystal
refer journal which was all about a way
to crystallize proteins it's just the
protein and the crystallize is is called
super paccheri the neither had a chat
with the first author of the of these
papers saying that she was about to
leave the last she had to kind of
publish this work that's been halfway
through of trying to engineer this super
potent version of cherry well although
this is kind of a half-baked product we
still tried to speed this super toner
cherry and it worked
the very first trial and we saw
complementing forces although it's
fairly weak so we so this to color image
is been produced by a form for extra
peds of a security level later when
semen are tried to improve the
brightness spread for the cherry speech
by well tearing the two fragments with a
32 amino acid linker and then doing
random ela Genesis DNA suffering and
direct
the ocean she has been derived is the
second generation of the space smoke of
the cherry that is almost a factor of
eight in sprite as the first generation
so these are the in Darjeeling
overexpressed taste and in the lower
right corner
they bring our weakness proteins using
the secretary to 11 now we have the two
colors we can do double knocking and
that means that that is a stable to do
some of our interesting things name of
example we've done double knock into two
of the ER proteins 61b and our 6 ft 1 &
6 1 D has been widely used as a ER
marker because it's a year trans local
protein and it's a social producing
phase suppose has nothing to do with the
yellow for G suppose addition to label
only yeah but to our surprise when we're
trying to label these two proteins we
seen at the very edge of the cell very
peripheral yars is special dead and yeah
Cheerios does the very strong our 651
that's your trigger protein neighboring
that's very little success won't be this
is not an artifact of GFP Devon versus
cherry never because we can swap these
two labels when we saw pretty much the
same pretty much the same thing at the
very periphery of of the cells the more
recently into the chameleon every girl
has published paper in they've also
observe the same phenomena and they have
some nice explanation of what may be
going now and that's associate with the
function for hours except you weren't
rooting in case this is the this is a
very nice illustration that's once we
have the capability of naval endogenous
proteins we can if we look at those in
various proteins we may have some nice
surprising discoveries that people have
never seen have not seen before because
of limitation living with them
the GOP Nevin amnion went to 11 as if
cherry in evidence of cherry to 11
where do you think about this as a
general approach to naval proteins and
typically what people label proteins
yeah this whole functional tag and they
put the tag on Atari project the stack
is big that may return the functional
proteins what sometimes we make the
neighboring macoing difficult in this
case in all these cases we'll see they
talk about so far were not tagging the
target protein with the entire tab we're
just tagging a pudding with a fragment
of this of the time and when the larger
fragments floating a SERP Azzam and
after the protein of interest is made
with the fragment to attack the two
pieces can come together that
reconstitute the whole functional tag
and that has a lot of advantages and in
in our case we talked about for some
proteins when there are other similar
peptides larger fragment Z directions
that's by tags by capture owns we can in
fact generalize that this whole frame
and tagging approach to many things mean
for example we can use this to crater
for the act for the active door for some
tax in this case we merged the six
mutations that converting and sherée
into
PM cherry and our mutations of
converting and cherry in just suit of
supercoder cherry to and that creates
the full activatable through fuller
cherry went to the in fragment its share
the same happy never fragrant with
cemetery to 11 so in this case we can we
can to endorse for the neighboring with
a full acronym for some protein and then
we can just refresh my cross made a
storm using expect that here showing the
storm image the
nicely resolved the fine structure
details of Catherine color pet similarly
we can do this thing with despite tax by
catcher in this case we actually used
the app in Devon fusing tanum chipping
them in fusing tenable spare tiles
that's still small enough to fit in a
two hundred nucleotides Torah DNA and
then GP never has a selection marker
then the Atari protein with a swipe tag
handle later after fixation we can do we
can do standing very efficient me with
the spy catcher protein that forms a
covenant I took have that balance with
the spy attack that bringing a for for
so that we can do we can also choose
similar to my CrossFit storm with
Dodgers proteins neighborhood by Tendo
chip endurance by tag the name is super
efficient because interaction between
sprite act as my character is he says
his covenant pretty much well completely
irreversible and we can use this tag for
other thing purpose as well previously
when Johnson and Aaron created at Easter
is actually two neighbors one chip in
library for imaging contact memory for
naming replication now with the
development of so many nice name
nobody is against share P once we have a
GMP never knock in every after I have a
dual function every ship in the Jimmy
Nevin coupled with service as a imaging
tag as well as a egg to tag for
immunoprecipitation in this case we can
do we can do puja endogenous proteins
and here's proof of principle
demonstration from a new number of
complexes who have been showing that we
can very creamy for down the other
component of the same same complex so we
are having a dual function library is
not only useful for microscopy and also
useful for chemical and even proteomics
and as it's
and with this name with this memory with
our ability to really scale things up as
to ping us to have a potentially genomic
still Gnabry of Leonardo's proteins
tapped by the friend tag which is is
actually the task of many the emetic was
now a group leader at the chance at
about bio ha then then offering one
empty we can really complete this
pipeline for the name for the entire
genome then turn these nice
illustrations by technical cell into
real pictures so that ends my transition
I like to think the people in my lab who
participated in this project I mentioned
to them during my talks I would like to
also thank our carbon errs that's making
all these things happening as well as
the funding agencies I'm 34 and of you
for listening thank you thank you dr.
crane for the informative presentation
we will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button our speaker
will follow up with your questions via
email and let's get started our first
question is will the function of the
target protein be perturbed when labeled
by GFP 11 well that's a very important
question of course with any being first
including tagging methods whether it's
not as pudding with its own expression
it's always important to make sure that
the tagged protein then does not have
it's a function perturbed and supposedly
in our case that's after although we are
tagging the protein with just the short
peptide GIP netted after commentation
you will be the same here the
as compared to when we tagged which are
approaching with further chippy
so theoretically you should not have
more perturbation compared to food and
chippy tagging in fact for when we are
trying to create our library with pick
the science that people have already
being tagged those proteins with Felicia
please to make sure that is no
functional no expected from perturbation
to the system we did see I am strangely
in a couple cases that's the target
protein is tolerating GP never
neighbouring but not so much with
foolish opinion a neighboring
potentially this is because that when
the rabbit was making approaching and
this especially when the Rebs
when the GOP is in started folding while
the ribosome is making the protein that
may perturb the folding of otário
protein potentially but GV Nevin is a
short peptide that may have much nest
predation but anyway I think it's always
we always need to be careful when namely
important with pretty much anything not
to prepare our target function and I
would say that GOP Nevin is not created
the one as Ness perturbation compared to
pruners a chippy if they are not having
the same amount of perturbation and what
is the affinity between the two
fluorescent protein fragments well
that's a difficult question because the
once the two fragments complemented the
whole proteins methods and cohort no
mature there's from our experience this
process is pretty much irreversible
which means that if you want to about
chemically measure the affinity between
these two fragments
it's a memory very difficult um however
I feel if we think these in treat this
process two steps when doing
first is to for supporting combined and
then they can fold and then they can
mature with the steal and a fairly issue
of the first process actually in our a
more careful a tradition that's the the
GFP for speed GFP the to fragment has
very very high affinity they come
together very efficient they are nearly
100 percent of the key never will be
being complimented by JP 110 and getting
too high for immature JP fully mature
GFP no this isn't not surprising giving
so much optimization that one of that
has done for this construct for the
newer speeds of neon green but they was
retained evan has speed surgery too
we realized that the communication
efficiency not is not one being meaning
that the still some affinity or unnamed
association if you're between the two
fragments before the fold and they even
respirating mature into a full found a
fully functional protein it is when one
subject that we are looking to at this
moment here we have one more question
well the expression of GFP one to ten
affect the cells that GP went in our
experience we've tried multiple cell
lines expressing in G if you wanna tell
more stable surrounds expressing gfp
we've even tried one IPS cell line
generating while stable IPS don't know
nice expressing gfp 110 JP one attends
seems to be pretty well tolerated in all
these cases but we do have to be careful
that when JP wanna tell it's not a
complete for protein in forward protein
and so the cell may have certain
alpha including response if does to
hiding expression
of jp1 hotel or they are - moaning -
higher concentration of I'm company
manager if you want to check was was is
in a Cell
now for the amnio green we have nothing
much difference in our limit experience
who have not see much difference
compared to GE one time in terms of our
cart revving up the growth of the cell
but for as a cherry want to tell we did
have seen a little more that accessibly
compared to JP one lieutenant as a cell
may grow floor while this to hiding
expression of the cherry one to ten in
there now these are our experience with
the with the cell 9 in general they are
pretty well tolerated by the cell line
but we do have to be careful not to
expel races too much and when one comes
to like in animals then for own isms as
compared to so nine they may be not more
sensitive we have created JP one to ten
Joseph I realized the the fries seems to
be all okay with it and so I think this
is a pretty interesting topic topic for
for the investigation of see how well
this is talking and this is tolerated by
myself by very sterilized diverse
organisms and how well we can improve
the whole system as to reduce their
potentials and a half toxin I would like
to once again thank dr. coin for his
presentation I would also like to thank
libraries for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through December of 2018 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us and we
hope to see you again soon goodbye